here's what i would compare
uh libertarian to if it was a religion
don't get upset here i'm just telling
you if you were a religion it's my
religion i would say you're like
scientology okay
and they have famous people they do i
was about to go there i was about money
i was about to go there i was about to
go there to say scientology for the
longest time have has been trying to
sell and if you go to scientology in
2002 i was a guy on the streets going to
every church i'm debating everybody i'm
trying to look what is this all about
and i'm an atheist at the time and i
would go to scientology and i would say
so so tell me who is god who do you
think god is
no i know i'm asking you who is god who
do you think god is
i said no i i'm asking you you're a
religion you have a 501c3 under that tax
code you're structured as a religion you
got that tax code back in the days you
have great lawyers who is god
who's got to you
i went everywhere asking people who is
god they couldn't tell me who god was
right i said okay
so whoever you want god to be that's the
argument whoever you want god to be is
your god okay how about this who do you
want it to be whoever you want it to be
so the philosophy is very much about
whatever you want to do is your whatever
you want to do whatever you want to do
right okay
you know
that attracted some people on whoever
you want to be ron hubbard wrote all
these books dianetics has started with
that and all this other stuff and next
thing you know
adam that kind of uh counter
contradicts the argument of having a big
name because they've had all the big
names over the years i mean you can't
get bigger names than these guys got
right they're saying scientology but
they haven't gotten bigger their
membership's going down it's not it's
not at the peak it used to be now maybe
it's because of miscavige maybe it's
because of whatever i'm not going to
talk on that all i'm saying is that part
now let me go to the other side
um
there are roughly 200
libertarian politicians out there almost
every one of them is local okay
you have a justin homage who ran as a
republican switch to a libertarian
michigan i want to say yeah and then
he's like i'm done right then you have
jeff hewitt who is the highest ranked
libertarian i think it's riverside right
county california he has a job there and
then you got a couple other guys that
are doing what they're doing that are
highly ranked right okay so to me
i think uh what you're doing is great
you got to go out and promote your
message and do what you're doing but i
think you guys got to get more grassroot
on the bottom to get more people selling
locally yeah and yeah to sell people
locally and then go to the top now what
would help on your end because yesterday
i'm like i'm sitting i'm like listen i
have a painting in my in my uh club room
in my house and a painting has milton
friedman there i'm a milton friedman guy
and milton friedman
what made him unique remember that
michael moore debate with milton
friedman i don't know if you've ever
seen it or not michael moore 17 years
old you ever seen this was that really
michael moore yeah i've seen people say
it was young michael moore but then i
saw other people be like that wasn't
mike no but the people that that's
that's michael moore who was debating
the whole pinto you know what all that
great great at that milton friedman
something else right so he but he was
all about debate right okay which is
essentially a little bit of the what's
going on right now there's a little bit
of pushback so let me see how this guy
sold it so the founder of libertarian
is this guy named nolan right david
nolan he starts in 1971 right of the
party colorado springs so why did he
start this what's his motive okay so it
was inspired by the austrian school of
economics not uh ludwig von mison it was
more murray rothbard and that time when
the party got started it was because of
four reasons one was nixon okay what he
was doing his administration they were
not ford is the vietnam war why do we
have to do this whole conscription i
think it's like when people are just
getting drafted without a choice yeah
and then it was a starter fiat gold
standard that was a time where he kind
of switched listen guys we gotta do
something about this so he created this
nolan chart and started going around to
everybody and talking about hey left hey
right you may not be what you think you
are you may be this and oh [ __ ] this
kind of makes sense for the world
smallest political choice by the way you
can get that quiz on the advocates.org
if you want to go to that quiz and it's
easy yes
the advocates.org the world's smallest
political quiz so there is an interview
milton friedman does i think everybody
has to watch i've one of them is phil
donahue if you haven't watched a 45
minute one part one i believe you got to
watch when he talked about a nader i
think he's someone nader but there's
another one that i watched that he is
being asked about the libertarian party
so what's the libertarian party and he
says look there's two ways of
libertarian party i've debated yar on
burke before i was a host of one of the
iron events that took place a few years
ago in newport beach
one he says is the iron rand one which
is like nothing
everything is there you leave everything
around and then there is the version
that he is more for which is hey you
know there's a little bit of a you know
consequentialist libertarianism he
explains then the guy starts asking
questions saying which one of these
federal government agencies do we need
to abolish which one of them to keep out
of the 1490s asking the question
department of agriculture agriculture
abolish department of education abolish
department of commerce abolish
department of defense keep it department
of energy abolish half put the rest
under defense okay department of health
and human services it's interesting what
he said he says well
yeah we kind of can but we need it
because of contagion and pandemic and
things like that department of housing
and development abolish he said this one
hurt america the most by the way housing
and urban you know housing and
development department of interior first
you have to sell the land that the
government owns why does the government
own on this land he says should
government have any land except for the
buildings that the government works out
of everything else give it to the people
you shouldn't own all this land
department of justice keep it the
problem of labor abolish department of
transportation abolish department of
state keep it department of treasury
keep it to collect taxes was the main
thing that he talked about department of
veteran affairs abolish
this is not fda cia cdc nih fbi nhs dea
fdatf which atf makes no sense alcohol
tobacco firearm what the hell we talk
about atf today and we've got all these
people working for them yeah
so so but so what so that's how he sold
it then he said the government's role
is a few things preserve the peace and
defended the country okay which is
defense
provide a mechanism whereby individuals
can adjudicate their disputes justice
department right protect individuals
from being coerced by others individuals
you know police and leave that at the
state and local level so
that's how milton sold it which part of
what milton said do you guys disagree
with today because this was nearly 40
years ago
well all of that would be a pretty good
start um so i think like i am more of a
uh rothbardian than uh than uh
friedmanite um i'm more i'm a
libertarian because i believe in natural
rights and i believe that government
destroys people's lives and i find that
morally egregious um but i do think that
this kind of consequentialist argument
is important also that things would work
a lot better uh if we left you know like
voluntary human action dictate them in
markets and rather than you know
top-down authoritarian states um i think
that
all of
there's so much of the federal
government that needs to be abolished
that getting into like whether or not
he's completely right about keeping the
justice department
i probably disagree i think that could
be handled by the states better
if in terms of keeping the defense
department i mean there should be a
drastic rollback of the
military-industrial complex the defense
department does not specialize in
defending this country they specialize
in starting aggressive wars for very
specific corporate interests at this
point there's not been a real defensive
need for the defense department since
certainly not in my lifetime um but you
really believe that
uh that what military 100 correct what
military election has in my lifetime has
there been one war that was a justified
defense of war well let me let me ask
you a question well okay 911 certainly
was a result of a lot of military
intervention preceding 911 i mean the
the people who attacked us on 9 11 were
people who we were sponsoring uh
teaching them how to lure the soviets
into afghanistan and bleed an empire dry
uh we then you know radicalized them
against us and certainly i don't think
that's the angle i'm going to 911 is a
byproduct of jimmy carter's bad policies
back in 1979 with the human rights
movement that he had he asked to sha to
release 3 000
prisoners that he had and the 3 000
prisoners that were released ended up
turning into isis and all that other
stuff so that that well hold on but
there's there's a lot of there's a lot
in between there so but also jimmy
carter in the last year as uh zabignu
brzezinski brags in his memoir that they
lo they were working to lure the soviet
union into afghanistan to give them
their own vietnam and then in the reagan
years we armed and trained the what was
the mujahideen in afghanistan which was
osama bin laden and the same group of
guys who turned into
into al qaeda we then under uh uh barack
obama sided with al qaeda and isis in
libya in syria and in yemen gave them a
whole bunch more weapons and and stuff
like that so there's been i mean yes 911
was awful we should have in response to
that killed and captured the the people
who were responsible for that but that
has nothing to do that has nothing to do
with a regime change war against the
taliban yes we could have cleaned that
up by christmas of 2000 but you're
saying we don't need a department of
defense not what he said okay you're
saying no we don't need 730 000
employees of department of defense yes
we don't need the trillion dollar a year
empire which we maintain what about the
hundreds of bases all around the world
close except 800 to be able china's got
one base close every single one of them
and bring every single troop home we're
not supposed to be an empire we're
supposed to be a republican we have no
need for our country for our defense it
does nothing to help the american people
this we every one of these troops should
come home protect our country protect
our borders that should be the role if
there is one of the federal government
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]